FEMA is offering to airlift displaced
Hurricane Maria victim from Puerto Rico
to the United States mainland this is
the first time the agency will fight
victims out of a devastated region to
stay somewhere else it is part of FEMA's
temporary sheltering assistance program
David Beck know is in San Juan to
explain how it works and the response it
is getting David good morning Charlie
good morning we're inside a shelter
where FEMA has actually come and asked
the people if they were interested in
taking part of this program nobody's
being forced to do so it's a volunteer
effort like this woman who was asked and
said yes I want to go there are two
states that are involved here Florida
and New York that's where people will be
taken details are being finalized but
the folks we've spoken to have said we
cannot wait to get out of here Glenda
Bonilla cologne is desperate to leave
this island she's been in this shelter
for more than 40 days
where I was born
74 year-old Elsie Ortiz's home was
heavily damaged by Hurricane Maria
inside the house on the water she too
has been here a little over a month
she's been approached by FEMA with a
chance to make her way to Fort
Lauderdale
while her home is being repaired and
they're gonna pay for you to come back
yes going and coming and the 15 days in
the hotel but after that everything else
is on me in most natural disasters FEMA
will pay for hotel rooms for long-term
displaced victims but there aren't
enough hotels on the island prompting
FEMA to come up with an airlift solution
Mike Byrne is FEMA's federal
coordinating officer here on the island
we have never done an average before for
this program and we have to take the
time to set it up because the last thing
we want to do is put people on a plane
have them arrive at an airport and not
have the wraparound services they'll
take care
Byrne says so far the program has yet to
gain momentum out of 300 families
interviewed 48 hours ago only 30 he says
showed interest edilene has been at the
shelter with her two kids for three
weeks she's one of those not sure about
going to the mainland she says she has
no money to support them if they go you
feel safer here even though you're in a
shelter
right now right now yes edilene and her
kids are sleeping here you know one of
the reasons they want to stay is because
the shelter is providing them food and
actually free health care so Nora even
though Mike Byrne at FEMA says you know
there seems to be a lack of interest
everything we found is there is more
about a lack of trust that people
wondering once you get me to that hotel
on the mainland what am I gonna do then
without a job all right David beg no
continuing your incredible reporting
form from Puerto Rico thank you so much